hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of good news gaming the show
that highlights all the good and fun
stuff from the weekend games just like
this unlikely appearance from Scoob and
the gang in GTA online first up this
week I absolutely have to talk about the
most wholesome streamer I've ever seen
Brock's regularly streams himself on
Twitch doing intricate wood carvings and
he went viral this week when this video
of him was broken out and people saw his
heartwarming reaction to being gifted
subs
there's someone give some sauce Brady
doesn't have to can I give the money pic
there's another clip where he says that
he doesn't want to accept donations
during the pandemic because of
everything else that's going on in the
world which is obviously such a lovely
sentiment he got lots of subs anyway I
think it's just really nice to see you
know one person being really kind and
then the outpour kindness from other
people there was actually a follow-up to
this story that happened rocks has been
a member of a fellow streamers community
for years and Panda TV realized that
Brooks didn't really have a decent rig
to play World of Warcraft on so Panda
dedicated an entire stream to raise
money to get Brooks a new PC and there's
been so much crummy news recently that
this genuinely warms my heart I think I
tweeted out that it made me cry a little
bit and honestly it did so I'm
definitely subbing to them both you
might remember a couple of weeks ago I
was talking about a company that were
holding meetings inside Animal Crossing
while that trend has exploded author
artist and illustrator Vivian Schwartz
has tweeted that they've been having
editorial meetings inside Red Dead
Redemption
I assume all day every day and I totally
agree with this tweet that zoom can suck
there's something about it that makes
you feel like you have to be on all the
time and it's very difficult to just do
what you would normally do so I love
this trend of people finding
alternatives vivian tweeted that it's
really nice to be able to sit at a
campfire and discuss projects with the
wolves howling
honestly that sounds pretty ideal to me
and now I'm just trying to think of
other games in which he could hold
meetings in like around the table in
Blizzard world on overwatch mmm
maybe right then gaming is an incredible
hobby and I don't need to tell you that
but one of the things I love about it
the most is that so many people from so
many different walks of life can come
together and enjoy it like hammock amore
who is per the Guinness Book of World
Records the oldest video game youtuber
at 90 years old and typically we don't
hear about all the people who play video
games but Mori is trying to change that
and speaks on her game my grandma
YouTube channel frequently about the
benefits of playing games particularly
for the older generation and she gets
through also it's like Resident Evil
Call of Duty but she has a real love of
gta5 and man I want to do a heist with
her all right now on to some more fun
stuff like this very specific subset of
memes DJ shack shout out to Jacob from
the game SWAT discord for sending this
to me and look I don't even know where
the original video of DJ Shack came from
but what I do know and love is that
there is an entire Twitter account
dedicated to making it look like Shaq is
DJing classic video game songs
so there's persona 3 Marvel vs. Capcom 2
Pokemon he's got them all but I think
the intro to San Andreas is my absolute
favorite
I find Dark Souls hard enough to play
just generally so imagine trying to play
Dark Souls without even looking at the
screen I'm obsessed with this clip from
don't rage quit which is an incredible
name on twitch who managed to beat the
asylum demon in Dark Souls first try by
only using her twitch chat to guide her
this is incredible she's not even
looking at the screen okay and finally
it's not really gaming but it kind of is
so I'll allow it this story is again
super heartwarming and a great note to
end the show on there is an adorable
tick-tock that went viral this week was
made by a postman who's reaching out to
Tony Hawk because a cute kid named
Cooper asked this postman to send a
skateboard to the man himself
tick tock obviously went viral and
replied Cooper's board is on the way to
Tony Hawk and in return Tony is sending
one of his actual skateboards to Cooper
it's such a sweet gesture from this
postman and it's gonna make this kid's
day alright that about does it for this
week's episode of Good News gaming as
usual if you have any heartwarming
stories fun things Daffy memes put them
in the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games when
teams are open if you want to DM me for
access to the games but discord we have
a good news gaming channel in there
where we share feel-good stories and
just chat about all things gaming movies
TV there's a great channel my current
favorite itch is photo mode masterpieces
where people share the cool pictures
they take in game it's a great community
we would love to see you there please
join hope you're keeping safe and we'll
see you next time
[Music]